que es concretamente lo que se está
prohibiendo por ejemplo a nivel federal
y cuáles son las sanciones previstas
Así es lo que se está prohibiendo son
estas llamadas terapias de reorientación
sexual también conocidas como esfuerzos
por corregir La orientación sexual e
identidad de género que pues lo que se
está prohibiendo en concreto son todos
aquellos tratamientos terapias servicios
que busquen impedir obstaculizar
restringir suprimir anular o menoscabar
la orientación sexual la identidad o la
expresión de género qué va a ocurrir con
aquellas personas que practiquen que
realicen o que financian Estas
actividades van a ser merecedores de una
pena de 2 a 6 años de prisión y también
de sanciones que van hasta las 2000
veces el valor diario de la unidad
mediana y actualización esto Es
aproximadamente nueve mil dólares y el
doble el doble de estas sanciones si se
trata de cuando la víctima sea menor de
edad adulto mayor o alguna persona con
discapacidad o también si hay alguna
relación de subordinación
médica laboral o académica son 11
estados los que ya habían aprobado esta
prohibición y ahora se hace como bien lo
mencionas a nivel Federal pasará a la
cámara de diputados para su aval Mario
por otro lado el estado de México aprobó
el matrimonio igualitario Cuál es el
panorama en el resto del país frente a
este derecho
es correcto el estado de México se
convierte hoy en la entidad número 29 de
32 que hay en el país en aprobar el
matrimonio igualitario o la unión de
personas del mismo sexo con 50 votos a
favor en el congreso local del estado de
México que es la entidad más poblada del
país con cerca de 17 millones de
personas se aprobó esta reforma legal
que permite estas uniones Cabe señalar
que las únicas tres entidades que no lo
permiten hasta el día de hoy Son Tabasco
son Tamaulipas y Guerrero la primera
entidad que lo aprobó fue la Ciudad de
México en diciembre de 2009 y hoy 13
casi 13 años después aún hay tres
estados que no lo aprueban el resto ya
sea porque han modificado su legislación
o por un mandato de la corte ya lo
aprueban porque hay que señalar que en
2015 la suprema corte determinó que es
inconstitucional prohibir las uniones de
las personas del mismo sexo en
matrimonio